هناك عصر الموضة
في الشرق الأوسط
وقد وصلت الحركة المتواضعة '
يبدو أنها موجودة لتبقى ،
فنحن أكثر من مجرد عباءة على
رؤوسنا أو أننا أكثر من مجرد معرفة
ما يظهر عليه  في الخارج
لدينا نفس القدر من الارتباط بالنسبة للنساء اللواتي
لا يغطين أو يقمن بالغطاء ، فنحن جميعًا ما
زلنا متشابهين ، لقد تم قطعنا من نفس القماش ،
وقد تكون هؤلاء المصممات
متواضعات في سلوك
الموضة العصرية في دبي ، إنها بوتقة انصهار  لذلك
أعتقد أنه يستعير أشياء مختلفة من
ثقافة مختلفة ، لذا فهي شوارع شديدة
الانفعال ، ويمكن أيضًا أن تكون كلاسيكية ، إنها أنيقة
، هناك العديد من الأشياء التي يقوم
بها مجلس الأزياء والتصميم الإسلامي في دبي
الذي أطلقوا عليه الحدث موضوعًا للاحتفال بالموضة المحتشمة.  لقد
دعوت أكثر من 35 مصممًا دوليًا ،
سنقوم بعرض مجموعات الأزياء المحتشمة الخاصة بهم
على الشركات الإقليمية ذات الوزن الثقيل
مثل Bloomingdale's Armani و
Boonton ، أعتقد أن ظهور
الحركة المتواضعة هو مثال رائع على
كيفية تعامل الجزيرة العربية  كونك أكثر قبولًا في
العالم الغربي ، يتعلق الأمر بنوع من
الشعور بارتداء ما تشعر
بالراحة تجاهه وليس كثيرًا إذا
كنت محجبة أم لا ، فالأمر لا يتعلق فقط
بتغطية نفسك ، بل يتعلق بالشعور
بالرضا أثناء القيام بذلك والمظهر
الأنيق  أنيقة وهي تعبير عن
الأناقة ، لذا فهي بالنسبة للجميع مصدر إلهام آخر
للتواضع ، صوفيا عبد الله
، المصممة الإقليمية الصاعدة
ومدونو الموضة ، أرى
زنابق الموضة تتطور إلى درجة
تصبح فيها نوعًا من أزياء الكيان الخاص بها.
هذا
شامل في الشرق الأوسط
والناس يدورون حول حياتهم
حقًا ، ولن ينمو
ذهني إلا في هذا الاتجاه الجديد هنا في
دبي حيث ترتدي الفتيات
بلوزات أزواجهن ، وهو أمر
أجده غريبًا حقًا ولكن  إنه لأمر
جيد جدًا في الواقع أنهم يمتلكون
فرديتهم وأنهم يمتلكون
حقيقة أن لديهم طرقًا مختلفة
للتعبير عن أنفسهم ونعم بالطبع
هم م  قوة أنفسهم من خلال إظهار
أنهم يستطيعون ارتداء ما يريدون
وأخذ أسلوب حديث في شيء
تقليدي للغاية وأنا معجب بذلك
وهي تخرج نفسها من عنصرها
وإخراجها من صندوقها وهو
شيء قوي للغاية ويتحدث
مع كل شخص.  أعتقد أن
الصورة التقليدية للمرأة المسلمة
كانت ترتدي عباية
أو ربما سيدة مكبوتة ولكن الآن
أعتقد أن العالم يرى حقًا
أننا مثل أي شخص آخر
نستيقظ ونفعل نفس الأشياء التي لدينا
نفس النضالات ولدينا نفس
الرغبات والعالم بالفعل
يلاحظ أن
غوتشي مارك جاكوبس ودولتشي غابانا قد
أدرجوا أزياء محتشمة في
عروضهم هذا العام ، حيث وضعوا الحركة المتواضعة
على منصة
دولية وتغيير التصورات عن AB الضخمة.
شعرت السيدات اللواتي تحدثت إليهن
أنه من الرائع رؤية
المصممين العالميين
يشيدون بالحقير أو يُدرجون
نماذج في عروضهم  كانوا يرتدون الحجاب
لأنهم اعتقدوا أنه كان
شاملاً للغاية وأنه ساعدني على
تحمل كل هؤلاء المفتي هو لاما بالنسبة لي
التي لديك في أوروبا والولايات
المتحدة ، يتعلق الأمر بالثقة في
ما
نرتديه  لا تنظر إلى شيء ما وتقول جيدًا
ما ترتديه لأن الجميع
يرتدونها مثل بعض الأشياء الغريبة مثل
الأشياء غير التقليدية ، فنحن لا نتوقف ونحدق وأنت
تعرف ما إذا كان كل شيء طبيعيًا ، عليك أن
تتوقع أي شيء هنا في دبي ، فهناك
كل اللمعان الذي يمكنك ارتدائه  بريق
في الصباح ليلا ، لا
توجد قواعد على محمل الجد
، حيث يتم إعادة ابتكار تعبير روحي عن الإيمان
والأسلوب وتقديمه في حزمة متواضعة ،
نحن حقًا نحاول أن نأخذ
الثور من قرونه كما يقولون إننا
نحاول أن نكون  المفكرين غير المألوفين بشكل لا يصدق
نحاول تحفيز الناس
وإلهام الناس للتفكير في
طريقة مختلفة لعرض
الأزياء وأنا ممتن لأن ذلك يحدث
على الموضة المحتشمة p  إذا نظرت
إلى النمو الهائل في قطع الأشجار
والتأثيرات وما إلى ذلك ، فهذا
يعكس حقيقة أن الكثير من النساء يحببن
التعبير عن
أنفسهن ويعرضن إبداعهن وتجميع الملابس
معًا وأعتقد أن هذا له
بعض القيمة بالنسبة لها  النساء في
المنطقة ومع جمهور جائع رقميًا
، الشرق الأوسط هو المرحلة المثالية
وأعتقد أنه في المستقبل
ستصبح الحركة المتواضعة أقوى
وأقوى وأعتقد أن النساء
سيستمرن في الشعور بالتمكين ليعيشن
حياتهن بالطريقة التي يعشن بها  أشعر أنهم
أحذية وأن الموضة ستدعمهم لحسن الحظ
وستقدم لهم تلك
الأدوات للنساء ليشعرن بالراحة
مع بشرتهن
[موسيقى]
أتمنى أن ألتقي بي منذ 20 عامًا عندما كنت
أعاني من أزمة الهوية برمتها
فقط ليقولها أحدهم  أنا أنظر
، سيكون الأمر على ما يرام ، إذا كنت
تريد ارتداء الحجاب ، فاحزر ما
الذي ستحصل عليه في هذه الوظيفة متعددة الجنسيات ،
ستتمكن من تسلق هذا الجبل الذي
ستفعله  قادر على تشغيل هذا السباق
[موسيقى]